my name is Ben kicker - I'm with STG
County at the Wolfram technology
conference today I'm presenting on how
to use the Wolfram technology stack to
work with the sustainable development
goals
I'm Maureen bear and I figured I'd start
right on time because we have lots of
good coding for you and don't want to
take up too much time just wanted to
give you a little bit of background of
why we're here about three years ago
I've been a wolfram hobbyist for about
ten years
and about three years ago exactly three
years ago I came here to a conference to
talk about the sustainable development
goals and how I saw the wolfram stack as
being very very good as a tool to work
with the sustainable development goals
to move ahead in terms of how people all
over the world could integrate their
stuff to share data and share
information on the goals at that
presentation three years ago I was very
optimistic both about what was going to
happen with his sustainable development
goals and how fast I could get things
done the first year first year and a
half was about waiting the sustainable
development goals were announced and
then it took another year and a half to
get them sort of pinned down and they're
still not pinned down they're set to
evolve what's happened over those three
years is two different things three
different things the first is that the
sustainable development goals there's a
lot more data out there both UN data and
other data the data is getting into
different shape different people are
looking from different perspectives the
second thing that's happened is that the
wool firm stack has gotten more powerful
in the sense of we're able to do things
that we wouldn't have been able to do
three years ago and the third thing and
probably the smartest decision I made is
that I have hooked up with two very good
data analysts and coders who I can sort
of say things too and they can figure
out how to do things so this is Benji
Bernstein who's one of the people is
working on our team and been kickert who
is going to take over the rest of the
presentation so thank you sorry Maureen
as Maureen mentioned my name is Ben
kickers I'm actually relatively new to
the Wolfram community only have about
six months where
of coding experience but I have been
turned on to what this means and how
this can be used when it comes to data
analytics my background is actually with
on-the-ground work data management and
assessment I spent seven years in
Swaziland Africa working both with local
NGOs as well as some of the national
level discussions around how we can
track the data to go a little bit deeper
into what the SDGs are if that's not
something that's familiar to you
the SDGs are the global goals within the
SDGs you're looking at 244 indicators
169 targets and 17 goals those then are
calculated across 255 geographic areas
within that as the UN likes to do you
have numerous groupings and sub
groupings within that the UN then likes
to disaggregate based on age gender
population measurement types now looking
at the SDGs you have a wide range of
data quality of those 244 indicators as
of this month only 93 indicators are
listed as being fully developed and
everybody agrees on how we're tracking
and where the data is coming from 77 of
those have been defined but are not
uniformly coming in from all member
nations and there's still 57 of those
that lack an agreed-upon collection
methodology so we still have a long way
to go when it comes to data quality
coming in for the SDGs for us in our
work looking at the the analytics of
that we find that the publicly available
data sources are largely found in three
broad categories you have the the
official UN results you have the
derivative analysis and then you have
some original primary data that's
feeding into those two I'm not going to
spend much time here my approach is to
kind of give you a lot of things that
you can see I give you the ability to
dig in deeper if you want to if you
start with the official UN SDG database
this is just a screenshot of the website
you can see that you can choose from any
of the goals the targets the indicators
you can pick what geographic area you're
interested in selecting data from and
you can look at what years you want so
if you want to know about maternal
health rates in Djibouti
in 2012 you can structure your data to
pull that out if you look up at the top
you realize that as it is of August
there's well over 1 million observations
that we're pulling from the full data
size is 300 megabytes for a CSV if you
look at the derivative analysis what you
find here is these are companies these
are organizations often funded by the UN
that are taking those large data sets
and saying we either want to make them
more readable more usable we want to
consolidate we want to be able to report
often what they're doing is they're also
giving you visualizations so here you
see a quick map of how each country is
doing and then different ways that you
can interact with the data the third
source of data we work with is what
we're calling original primary source
data so if you take the World Health
Organization when it comes to
tuberculosis they're considered the gold
standard internationally and so their
data datasets are incredibly robust
where the UN reports on one indicator
for TB the the w-h-o will give you 20 or
30 different indicators and so that
feeds into the UN database if you want
to dig in you can do that through those
types of sources now when it comes to
accessing the SDG data one of the things
we have to our advantage is because of
the emphasis on the importance of data
in international development there's
been a lot of raw data that's been made
available to people like you and I so
what I'm gonna do is quickly look at
three of those sources that we talked
about so you can kind of see what what
any of you can go and and download and
analyze if you want to this first one is
the official it's it's a sample set of
the official UN s e-g data you see it
talks about the goals targets indicators
you can see what country it's coming
from you can see how they're measuring
it by age by gender what the value is
the SDG index on the other hand is
pulling in a broader data source here
they're gonna give things like under
five mortality as a single figure
they're going to give you incidents of
tuberculosis as a single figure and then
in TB you can see that every
is being divided out by different age
segregations
looking at things like HIV and TB
comorbidity now one of the things we
find is that when you're dealing with
large and diverse datasets it's
important to not just deal with the flat
data but to also look at how these
things are connected relationally
Wolfram is not set up as a database
software and in kind of its purest form
but we found that there's actually ways
that we can take this diverse data set
put them together and find some of these
relational connections so one of the
things we've been working with is
something we call relational entity
stores it's kind of a fancy name that
we've added to it but it's nothing
different than what you see with most of
the entity's stories that Wolfram hosts
so if you look at country data for
instance you pull up the capital city
from the country data it's going to give
you an entity that you can then follow
and find out information about the
capital city we've done the same thing
we were looking at things like that the
descriptions of the SDGs the goals
targets and indicators so if you look at
the properties this is an entity store
that we've created if you look at the
properties you see we're pulling in the
official UN code the description but
then we've added a property value for a
parent goal and parent target if you
look down at the actual properties
themselves you realize that for
indicator 2 point 1 point 1 we have a
parent goal of 2 and a parent target of
2 point 1 besides having the nice pretty
squared box around it it actually does
some other things as well because we've
nested our entities within our
properties now with with simply adding a
single one more single line of code to 2
what we're looking at instead of just
looking at the description for an
indicator we can pull the description of
its target its parent target as well as
parent goal so here we see that
indicator two point one point one is
about undernourishment which is a part
of the global goal to end hunger you can
also do things like pull descriptions
for all of the goals that are related to
goal 10 or all of the indicators that
are forego
ten one of the things that we've done is
kind of changed the way that we do our
data analysis is we've taken these
entities that we've created and then
incorporated them into otherwise flat
datasets so at the bottom under SDG
relational data we've taken this sample
and we've incorporated the entities that
are related to the the descriptions
behind them so now instead of just
having the UN data as it gives it to you
now you can tap into Wolfram you can tap
into all of the the power of the entity
stores and it's not just your own you
can also do it the same way with country
data so here we know that our first
entry and our SDG relational data set is
from South Africa so we've replaced the
name South Africa in an otherwise flat
CSV with the country data for South
Africa that we can then pull from the
Wolfram entity store so the significance
of this is just with a few lines of code
and this would work for anything not
just the SDGs you can take flat data and
then connect it to much broader data
sets and do multi-dimensional analysis
now what I want to do and and I'm not
going to get into any of the code
everything in this notebook is fully
functional you can download it from from
the website run through the whole thing
if you want to instead I want to show
you an example of how we've been using
the Wolfram technology stack to do some
analysis so we're going to start by
looking at some of this SDG relational
data set that we just created where we
took a flat CSV we added our own entity
data for descriptions as well as the
country data so doing something
relatively simple we start with the raw
counts for country data how many
countries did I put into my sample set
you see I've got five and you can see
how many data points I have for each of
them
because it wasn't just countries but it
was actually entities that we
incorporated into that we can then take
that information and pull in information
from Wolfram to give us more information
so let's look not just at what countries
they are but let's pull the life
expectancies for those countries so now
our UN data allows us to easily connect
and create a visualization where
we now have a color-coded graph of our
countries that show you not only who are
we reporting on but how are they doing
in life expectancy
you see Swaziland in South Africa not so
great our neighbors to the north they're
living a little longer than we are now
looking at what we put in ourselves we
want to look at the indicators that
we're tracking you can see that I'm
taking a selection of about five
different indicators you can see how
that data is spread out and I only have
seven data points on three point seven
point one but I have a lot of
information on three point three point
one so let's figure out what that's
about because it's just a number in the
flat data set so I see that this one is
about HIV infections how many you have
per 100,000 now let's go back to that
relational data set and look at look at
the indicators and country distribution
let's dig a little bit deeper into HIV I
know from seven years working in the HIV
world that they like to split their data
a hundred different ways and don't
always know how to put it back together
so what we want to do is say ignore you
know I I don't care how many females and
rural settings that are under 17 years
of age that in itself doesn't give me
what I need so just give me the
information where I have all the sex
data and I have all of the age data so
here we now have a second level data set
that's just focusing on all of the
information we have for cumulative HIV
statistics if we want to visualize that
by year we actually see that it was only
South Africa and Swaziland who's
reporting on this which is relatively
common because the amount of investment
in HIV in a country like that we can now
look and see what sort of trends we have
across years the trends over years are
helpful if you want to visualize that
but at the end of the day I want to know
maybe what the max HIV rate was where
did Swaziland spike or I want to know
what is the most recent data that we
have so again using the built-in wolfram
functions we can easily pull that from
the UN data
if you wanted to look at something
rather random you could also look at
something like the mean you know what is
the what is the average across all of
the indicators that you're reporting on
now because we're dealing with just a
single sample set
that's not indicative of the whole we've
definitely got some gaps but as we
mentioned earlier there are a
significant portion of the SDGs that
countries don't even know how they're
going to be reporting on so we want to
be able to take a look at how that
reporting is coming in so here we get a
number for how many countries have
reported or how many times is each
country reported on each indicator and
if you look at three point three point
two this is the second box you realize
we have very very consistent data in
three point three point two but again I
worked with this every day but I don't
remember all the numbers using our
embedded entities we can pull out the
description not only of that indicator
but also how it fits into the larger
targets and goals
now with TB data when we're looking at
that TB that it doesn't just report a
single figure when you're looking at the
the incidence per 100,000 instead they
have high bounds low bounds and mid
bounds so we want to pull out just those
mid bounds and with that just like we
did with our life expectancy now we can
create a geographic visualization where
you see the tuberculosis is it's quite
an issue in southern Africa Canada in
the u.s. we're gonna do okay at the end
of the day what makes this linking
between your own data public data and
the Wolfram data so helpful is in in a
couple lines of code you can pull out
that chart that's actually going to show
you not only the TB rate that we got
from the UN but also also the life
expectancy rate for each country looking
at that from a global perspective again
using the the Wolfram technique of
natural language we can simply ask it
what is the what is the global life
expectancy for the entire world with
that we've got a chart that not only
shows us what the TB rate is which I'm
guessing most people don't know the diff
it's between a rate of 10 and a rate of
100 in terms of is that good or bad but
we can see how that rate corresponds to
life expectancy and then show it as a
percentage of the overall global life
expectancy so in Switzerland they have a
hundred their life expectancy is a
hundred and fourteen percent of the
global average and they only have a TB
rate of 7.8 and where I'm coming from is
showing 400 and has actually one of the
lowest life expectancies in the country
at less than 70% of the global average
and these are just examples that that we
are showing is kind of a one-time
through of how we're using our
information the same idea of creating
relational data sets with either your
own into these stores or wolfram
entities can be used in many ways now
I'm going to quickly go over this if
this is something you're interested in
you're more than welcome to dig a bit
into the code the the original
presentation is we're going through the
example I had the long code written out
but one of the things we wanted to do is
actually be able to automate a lot of
these processes so we created a couple
defined functions that were specifically
set up to help us create these
relational data sets the first ones very
easy simply creates flat data returns
flat data into a data set we can then
take a list and turn it into entities
that can either be your own entities or
because it uses the interpreter function
you can also turn that into say company
data using that that same code you can
then use data set entity replace so say
you you scrape a table from Wikipedia
about the top 50 countries our companies
in China you can use this to then
replace that flat data with the company
data also what you can do is if you
don't want to do a replace which is what
I'm showing below you can append an
entity to your existing data set so here
in our scg index we had all of the
information about Afghanistan but what
I've done is I've actually added the
entity Afghanistan is the first column
so again that allows you to dig deeper
and do multi-layer analysis where you're
pulling in data not only from the
country it's
self in the Wolfram repository but also
from the information that you're
bringing to the table so to close if you
look at the conclusions that we've come
to in doing this work around the SDGs
we really have found that using entities
as properties and and having that multi
layer aspect really allows you to not
only to move away from flat data and
into a relational context we found that
the Wolfram environment compared to
something like Excel is very powerful
for parsing and analyzing complex data
that's coming in from multiple sources
and as I said before we find that
relatively easily users can combine this
public data with the Wolfram data to
create multi-dimensional analysis now
some of the challenges we've run into
the automation of the process does
require that your data is relatively
clean to begin with we're fortunate that
you end data tends to be a little bit
cleaner than some other sources it's not
perfect but at least they try to be
consistent but we have run into issues
in the past another thing when you're
looking at data storage management
access distribution our team is spread
across four states and so trying to
coordinate the different findings that
we have can be a little bit difficult
when you're losing using some of the
cloud-based solutions so a 300 megabyte
CSV is manageable on your computer in
Excel but by the time you convert it
into a relational data set and start
running your analysis on that if that
becomes a cloud object we run into some
issues with that also we found that the
Wolfram interpreter function is not
flawless there's times where we have a
few results coming back that aren't
linking us to the data that we expect in
terms of opportunities and next steps
one of the things that we want to do is
to explore integrating multiple data
sources into a single a single unit and
so here I've shown our sample SDG data
and I've shown the SDG index data and
I've shown that we have the TB data
ideally we want to be able to package
that so it's all one piece that can be
easily accepted the other thing and
we've actually been in conversations
this week about it we want to continue
to look at some of what's considered
gold stay
data sources and to be able to compare
it to what's in the Wolfram repository
to either update and provide that
information to others who may find it
useful or also to understand where
there's gaps when we are pulling in
external data I'm one of the people that
has sat in and listened to Steven
Wolfram's
live seeing CEO e twitch and YouTube
sessions and one of the things they've
been talking about that got me excited
sending emails it's all hours of the
night is something they're talking about
related to entity extend I'm speaking
simply from what I've heard in the
discussions but at the end of the day
you're looking at at being able to
append additional properties to existing
entities which for us we're having a
workaround but that's exactly where
we're wanting to go and also for those
of you that were in Stevens keynote at
the beginning of the week when he popped
up his database connection to an SQL
that automatically converted everything
into an entity store I almost fell out
of my chair because that was a huge step
forward when you look at where local
data is where public data is and what it
means for being able to build these
these relational connections I think we
have a few minutes for questions if
there's anything from the crowd we've
put our information up on the screen
we'd love to be in touch feel free to
use our code or retouches